now we're government closed the cities
and then we realized that this was
really dangerous it definitely feels
like a movie the streets are empty and
all the stores are empty the situation
is very dramatic your brain starts to
function in another way to survive so
it's very difficult because we are not
free but we are together all over the
globe there are people doing things from
their balconies and windows when I saw
this I thought we should do that as well
music has the power to change a bad day
you can tell but no but corner the table
you need have to take a semi most of all
I am NOT a doctor I cannot heal people
but I can give hope and I can make
people fly with me in a perfect world at
least for five minutes a day
I think that people are using art to
express their deepest senses of joy it's
just at the end of the day human
connection is a balance of being
realistic and also you know being able
to smile
[Music]
people cannot go to the gym but it
doesn't mean they can't get a workout KC
naphthyl and Matt green held their
wedding online yesterday complete with a
flower girl
orderly trying to be their best versions
of themselves right now I think that's
all we can ask so many families are
missing milestones with a little
improvising they got to meet their
newborn great-grandson a strict no
visitation policy at this retirement
home hasn't stopped Charlie Johnson from
seeing his 88 year old father albeit
through a window amid the corona virus
outbreak many people are in need and
volunteers are stepping in to assist the
elderly we just decided to post a note
and put it where we sometimes run into
our neighbors so that they feel and know
that their neighbors have their back
right now grocery delivery
pharmaceutical deliveries whatever it is
that they need from outside if they
don't want to go out our thought was
kind of like okay you can shoulder some
of the responsibility and our own
individual communities we have never
been so close you know because we are a
team now musicians have set up washing
stations to protect the homeless
Melbourne sake community rallying to
prepare meals for delivery to anyone
most in need
the Cuban medical Brigade is on the way
to Europe the people who are now working
hi there maybe not the people who get
the most applause in everyday life we
just take them for granted so so now
people are just applauding them
I hope that one this fall passes that we
all still have the same amount of love
and respect for each other that we have
at this time
[Music]
we're showing that we we're all bound
together even though we have to stay
apart
you